there are four things one two three four
under binomial theorem that you already
know how to do skills okay so they all
flow from this simple idea they all flow
from this simple idea firstly what's a
binomial
what is it better yeah it's - well terms
yeah so when you look at something like
this a plus B and then you raise it to
some kind of power right we call this a
binomial expansion right so we explore
this idea and we said okay if we
introduce some new notation factorials
and see ours this kind of thing this
right
once you use these new kinds of ways to
describe things and represent what's
going on you can explain you can
articulate what each of the coefficients
in that expansion is going to be okay
and we came up with the binomial theorem
that the are as in are th the our
coefficient in something raised to the
power n is equal to now does anyone
remember in factorial notation what it
is it's a fraction yeah and what yeah Oh
toriel very good okay it's right to
that's it okay there we go okay so this
is the binomial theorem after which this
topic is named okay so he said okay this
is what by those are we explore Pascal's
triangle you've got that relationship
out of there and then from this one idea
we developed four skills okay so the
simplest one simply is expanding right
so if you have some a plus B to the
power n whatever and you like you can
expand that thing and they're very the
simplest question that can be asked is
here's a binomial extension can you just
tell me what all the terms of going to
be okay so we could expand so I want to
give me suggestion what's something else
you learn how to do okay so you could
find I'm gonna put something third one
you could find the coefficient
of a specific term so it's like if you
only want this coefficient like usually
we specify that by a power so for
example give me the coefficient of the
the term which is an a cubed inner in
this thing okay then we can use this to
go straight there you don't need to
evaluate all the rest of you'd have to
write out the whole thing you can just
use this theorem and go immediately to
ejector okay before that before that we
had this thing called the general term I
don't know what the general term is
general yeah
yeah very good so what we would say is
another color we would say something
like this this thing is equal to once
you write the whole thing up it's the
sum of now how many terms will there be
in this thing okay
what we say is we start from the zeroeth
term you got to the end term right so
for example a plus B whole square it's
got three terms in it right
it must be cute it's got four terms in
it so that's why you have a zero term at
the beginning what to do for us you set
us up to end to there n plus one in
total now what are the things we're
adding up things with an e I'll give you
clue there's this guy and then there's
two other pieces after it okay so the
first bit is that is the actual
coefficient and then
okay so you can write this in two ways
okay you can say well let's tie in terms
of it about a so how that one is
straight arm
this is whichever our coefficient is and
that means how many of the other things
will there be in there binomial
it'll be M take away ah all right so for
example the first two let's let's call
this like say N equals seven please
okay your first term will be a to the
seventh there are no bees or rather
there are zero beans and then the next
one is going to be a six big one a five
b2 and these things are always adding up
to M right does that make sense so we
use this like this statement here the
general term that's the general term
okay
that is like how can you generally say
any particular term that's it now lastly
stepping away from the expansion's just
a little bit I'm something that we
looked at was identities so we looked at
some very simple identities that you
could articulate in terms of this thing
okay so I'll give you the simplest one
there are three which I hope you can
remember off the top of your head the
simple point goes like this we can write
them all down and choose 0 and n choose
M they're both equal to each other and
they're both equal one good so these are
like on the ends of Pascal's triangle
yeah
entra zero inches and both of them are
equal to one what's another idea does
anyone remember any other identities
yeah I like an you're sure all right
wasn't war my hand in mine but it's fine
it does to go ahead and it comes out on
the other ones I thinking off well
mainly from like the Pascal's triangle
idea so for instance we know that
Pascal's triangle is symmetrical right
his reflectional symmetry so if you
looked at the earth coefficient like our
cannula one two three four all the way
up to our it should be the same as if I
come from the other side and count our
this way right so this should be and
true okay so this was the symmetry
property there was one last one if I
take all of these animal off on any
given road right does anyone remember
what happens when you add up all of the
numbers in a row of Pascal's triangle
yeah very good to the okay and there was
a wonderful one life proof for that I
know if you remember it you can I could
demonstrate for you again if you'd like
but it's outside the scope what I would
do